“One is the loneliest number …”
Hey everyone, Crystal here for DNews.
I don’t care how much Netflix and ice cream
you consume, being alone for long periods
of time SUCKS.
It makes us sad, eats away at our self-esteem
and our immune system, makes us more susceptible
to chronic diseases and may even shorten our
lifespan.
But could loneliness actually be a good thing?
Loneliness is the emotional state that arises
from perceived isolation.
Like Hunger, Thirst, and Pain, Loneliness
is an “aversive cue:” a negative feeling
that we want to move away from.
Think of it as an evolutionary mechanism that
says “hey, you’re in danger and friends
could help”.
Humans evolved to be social animals: groups
provide protection and shared resources that
help us survive.
When it comes to gathering food, building
shelters, and defending themselves, communities
of humans have a much better chance of survival
than individuals do.
And so scientists say, we evolved a “need
to belong”.
In fact, loneliness may have been so important
for survival that we evolved a unique set
of neurons in our brains dedicated to it!
In a paper recently published in the journal
Cell, neuroscientists at MIT identified a
region of the mouse brain that is uniquely
responsive to isolation.
The researchers used a technique called optogenetics,
in which light is used to activate or inhibit
selected groups of neurons in a modified rodent
brain, to manipulate a cluster of Dopamine-sensitive
neurons in the Dorsal Raphe Nucleus, (which
is a region of the mouse’s brain that’s
been associated with depression).
For now let’s call this special set of cells
“loneliness neurons”.
In the study, researchers introduced a lonely
experimental mouse to a new mouse friend,
and observed a significant increase in activity
of the “loneliness neurons”.
Then they gave the mouse a choice between
spending time alone or with another mouse
and studied how optogenetic stimulation of
the “loneliness neurons” influenced the
mouse’s choice.
Activation of the neurons caused the mouse
to spend significantly more time with a mousy
companion then alone, indicating that when
the neurons fire mice seek out social interaction.
But was the mouse’s choice motivated by
positive reward or a negative experience?
To determine this, scientists let mice roam
around in a box that contained two areas.
When the mouse spent time in one area, its
“loneliness neurons” were stimulated,
while in the other area, they were not.
Interestingly, the mice avoided the stimulating
area indicating that the activation didn’t
make them feel very good.
This observation lead researchers to suggest
that activity in this brain region may be
connected to a loneliness-like state that
motivates mice to seek out social contact
to feel better.
These finding reinforces the evolutionary
view that loneliness is actually a good thing,
because it encourages us to seek social contact
and in turn keeps us healthier and safer.
Even in just this study there is so much more
to the story, and if the research is extrapolated
to humans it could not only help to explain
motivations behind our own feelings and behavior
but also help us study what happens when those
things go awry.
But before we all get too excited the neuroscientist
in me must extend a note of caution: it’s
important to remember that human brains and
mouse brains are similar in some ways, but
not the same and mice do not display identical
social behaviors to humans.
But for now, since we can’t manipulate human
brains the way we do with mice, we have to
make do with what we learn from rodents...and
hope that somebody gave those lonely mice
a hug and some tiny ice cream and told them
that they’re terrific and it’s all going
to be okay… you’ll find somebody who will
love you for who. you.
are. and you’ll never be lonely again…sorry
Well, if I haven’t managed to convince you
to stop staring at this screen and seek social
contact, check out this video by Laci on how
loneliness can kill you:
What about you?
How do you deal with loneliness?
Subscribe to DNews and let us know in the
comments down below.
See you next time!